This system of equation has exactly one solution and it is a point of
intersection. This point satisfies both of the equations. If I plug in an x
value of 4 and a y value of 45, both equations should be true. Let's see if that
works. Sure enough, in the end, we get true statements. If we can understand
that the solution to a system is a point of intersection, then we can use this
to solve all sorts of other problems. But before we get into solving other
problems we're going to see if a point is a intersection to a system, and look
at other types of systems. The x and y values make both equations true. This is
how we can check whether or not the point is actually a solution to our system
of equations.